i think it's absolutely amazing and this
is a a great day for
for the country it's a great day for
for london the the greatest city on
earth because what you've got now is uh
an extraordinary east-west
fast link that that will take people uh
from from kent uh
to essex to uh uh
uh sorry from ethics right the way
through to to berkshire and totally
transform opportunity in this in this in
this city and that was what we always
wanted to do i was i remember being here
um
2009 when we started it off and it's
fantastic to see it completed it was
wonderful to see her majesty uh open in
in in such fine form
and i really think that this will bring
people back into uh mass transit in the
city it will bring people uh back into
their places of work i think it will be
a transformative
investment not just for london but for
the whole country
as as we've already said it's 72 000
jobs it's created already it would it
will drive investment throughout the uk
because some people outside london might
say yet again london's got another big
money project
well you know i've got absolutely no uh
embarrassment as a as a former mayor of
london about supporting great projects
in london and we've got to do uh
crossroads we've completed cross road
but frankly there is more that we should
be doing we should be looking at tax
increment financing like we did with the
battersea extension the northern line
down to battersea to look at projects
such as the bakerloo line extension but
i think the real thing for us now is to
think about crossroad 2 and with the old
hackney chelsea line chelsea hackney
knight that is that is going to be
transformative again all the problems of
uh commuters coming in to waterloo
getting up to
north london you can fix that uh with
another another cross rail so
i think we should be getting get getting
on with that people say oh no it will
change people will
go working from home now we don't need
mass transit i profoundly disagree mass
transit is the thing uh public transport
is the thing that gives people
opportunity it allows people uh to get
uh cheaply and conveniently from where
they live to the place where they can
have a good uh high-wage high-skilled
job it's vital for leveling up could ask
you a couple of questions about the
northern ireland protocol
we can't afford a trade war can we win
at a time like this
that's looking increasingly likely if
you go ahead with the legislation being
proposed
i don't think that is likely but what we
have to fix is the
the problems with the the northern
ireland uh political situation where you
can't get the executive up and running
uh right now uh in the past we've done
all sorts of things to to fix that we
need to address the problems with the
with the protocol um what that actually
involves is getting rid of some uh
relatively minor barriers to to trade
and uh
i think they're a good common sense
called pragmatic solutions we need to
work with our eu friends to to achieve
it despite your visit yesterday you
hadn't convinced the dup have you
i think that it
it's important that all political
parties
who
believe in the government of northern
ireland get back around the table and uh
and get stormwarned up and running
northern's got amazing opportunity now
parts of the northern irish economy are
going really really well what they need
is leadership they need their
politicians to focus on the things that
matter to the people of northern ireland
the governor of the bank of england said
yesterday he feels helpless do you feel
helpless no i think that this country
has uh got a fantastic future and if you
look at just what
some of the data that we're seeing now
uh it's so unlike previous economic
problems in in in the uk
unemployment which was you know
you know you're younger than me but when
when we were kids unemployment was the
thing that was so devastating uh
in the 80s and the 90s millions of
people are on the scrap you've now got
unemployment at the lowest levels since
1974.
now what we've got to do is make sure
that we fix some i think short-term
global inflation issues caused by uh
coming out of the pandemic particularly
on supply chains particularly on the
cost of energy but we have the fixes
we're putting in uh the energy supply
the british energy security strategy
that we need plus because of the
the strength of the uk economy coming
out of kobit we're going to continue to
support people through the uh through
the choppy period but we will get
through in in in very good shape let's
go back to the northern ireland treaty
how can you justify breaking a treaty
you signed i think the the
the prior the higher uh duty of the uk
government
is to uh in international law is to the
good friday
agreement and the peace process and i
that's the that's the
the thing we have to uh
really look to
and uh
of necessity we can make some changes i
think to
the protocol which is not the law of the
needs and the persians it's i'm you know
i i agree it's there in article 13.8
that if things aren't working uh you can
change it
plus it makes it very clear on the face
of the text that
you should ensure the uh east-west trade
and the integrity of the uk internal
market so let's fix it uh we don't want
to nix it we want to fix it and we want
to work with our eu partners to do it
final question on
nato sweden and finland if president
erdogan blocks it what will you do
i think that the case for uh
for sweden and finland coming in is is
very good the swedes and the finns have
made an absolutely historic decision and
i think that mature consideration by all
friends and partners in nato will
invite everybody to conclude that this
is the right way forward